So now that we've talked about shutdowns,
let's talk about why we have them and why
we are not in a position to open in any significant
way.
We're not doing enough testing.
Some of the tests don't have a quick enough
turnaround time and we don't have a proper
contact tracing infrastructure.
And I know that this may be boring stuff,
but I think it's important to go through so
that it's not a mystery to anybody.
We are not unable to open because governors
are authoritarian dictators, that that's not
why when we see other countries starting to
open up.
And yet here we have so many health experts
say we're just not anywhere close to ready.
The reason is that the Trump administration
hasn't built a proper testing system or a
proper contact tracing system, despite constantly
bragging that we have the best tests and the
most tests and all of this stuff.
So let's explore it.
Why do we need more tests to open?
We have about a million official cases right
now, a little more than that closing in on
1.1 million.
Every antibody tests that's been done so far
suggests that the real rate of cases is at
least three times the official rate, maybe
as many as 20 or 30 times the official rate.
So what that means is we're only testing a
fraction of the people who have the virus.
This means you have likely millions of people
who don't know that they have it, who are
going around spreading it, especially the
asymptomatic people.
If we were testing at really high levels,
you could ensure that everyone who has any
symptoms at minimum could get tested and know
if they have it.
If the turnaround of the tests was uniformly
faster, people could learn more quickly that
they have it and immediately quarantine as
opposed to maybe quarantining, maybe saying
add or know that I have it, I'm gonna keep
walking around.
And if you had proper contact tracing infrastructure,
you could immediately contact the individuals
that had been potentially exposed by every
new case and say, hey, your friend, your coworker
or whatever has been exposed has tested positive.
You now need to isolate for 14 days.
This is what South Korea did.
And they had their first case on the same
day that we did.
Now, what is the truth about testing levels?
Because there's a lot of disinformation here.
Dr. Foushee has said we need to be testing
at roughly 3 to 4 million tests per week to
realistically think about opening.
So in the last seven days, we have tested
1.5 million people.
That's an average of two hundred and twenty
two thousand people per day.
This is better than early April, no doubt.
In the first seven days of April, we averaged
one hundred and forty three thousand tests.
Today, in the last week, we've averaged two
hundred and twenty two thousand, an improvement
of about 50 percent.
But it's been an entire month.
They said by the end of March we would have
tested tens of millions of people.
That date came and went and we are still only
testing about two hundred and twenty thousand
a day.
So as a bare minimum, as an absolute bare
minimum, we have to test 500000 thousand people
per day reliably, which is more than twice
where we are right now.
There are public health experts who say we
really need a million tests today.
There is one model that says we need 20 million
tests per day.
I mean, that's science fiction at this point,
particularly until you have an antigen test.
Right now we have RNA tests, until you have
antigen tests.
It would be very difficult, really impossible
to test at that level.
So instead of actually increasing testing,
Donald Trump spends his time bragging and
lying.
Even this morning, Donald Trump tweeted, quote,
We are doing far more and better testing than
any other country in the world.
And yet the media does nothing but complain,
no matter how good a job is done.
The same as with the ventilators.
They will never say we are doing a great job.
They will only viciously gripe the data's
public.
If you look at the top testing per capita,
the United States is forty third in the world
in testing per capita.
We're behind Belgium, but we're ahead of Belarus.
Now, some people say you can't really compare
the US to the Faroe Islands.
You have to eliminate the tiny countries from
that list.
Well, OK, if you concede that the US as a
country is twenty seventh in the world among
reasonably sized countries.
So we are nowhere near the top of the numbers
are public.
If you're out there complaining about my state
isn't open, my governor is a dictator or whatever.
Just look at testing.
If Trump spent half the time that he spends
bragging about testing actually working to
increase tests, we could be testing five hundred
thousand a day by now.
We could be testing 750000 a day by now, and
we could be having more reasonable conversations
about actually opening up.
This is why we are not ready to open in any
significant way at this point in time.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm
on Twitter at
Packman